estas imágenes fueron tomadas en
daredetza en el noroeste de Siria
algunos Rebeldes del grupo hayat alsam
incautan drogas en el puesto fronterizo
el montaje es impecable afirman haber
incautado miles de bolsas de captaban
estafetamina producida muy gran escala
en Siria especialmente desde la guerra
civil es derivada de un medicamento
utilizado para tratar la narcolepsia y
los trastornos del estado de ánimo hasta
tal punto que el captaron se ha
convertido en el principal producto de
exportación del país un mercado ilegal
estimado en varios miles de millones de
dólares este traficante sirio accedió a
hablarnos de lo que hay detrás de este
comercio prefiere permanecer en el
anonimato
afuera es una jungla todo el mundo tiene
hambre y todo el mundo quiere comer pero
aquí tenemos buenas relaciones con los
Rebeldes y con los tipos de Damasco y
homes
reciben cargamentos de la cuarta
división
tienen un trato con ellos como decimos
acá
[Música]
si pones dinero en sus manos harán los
de la vista gorda
la cuarta división blindada es la unidad
de élite del ejército sirio y según
Fuentes concordantes estaría en el
corazón del tráfico de captaban en las
zonas controladas por el régimen de
bashara-sat su comandante majera la SAT
no es otro que el hermano del dictador
sirio Aunque da más con niega cualquier
implicación y acusa a organizaciones
terroristas varios informes señalan el
papel activo de esta brigada la cuarta
división estaría implicada Incluso en la
fabricación de captaron y el transporte
de cargamentos a los puertos del ataque
ahí tartus al parecer en la región de
Damasco y en las provincias de zuleida
Higuera en el sur también habría
laboratorios para la fabricación del
estimulante
cuando recibimos la droga del régimen ya
está empacada
la cuarta división la empaca en cajas y
nosotros nos encargamos de la
distribución
no cambiamos nada
el precio de una píldora de captaron
conocida como la droga de los
terroristas oscila entre 1 y 25 dólares
todos los días pasan cargamentos enteros
a través de la porosa frontera con
Líbano en 2021 se incautaron 400
millones de píldoras en la región el
resto Sigue inundando los países vecinos
como lo revela este intermediario
libanés en el valle de la beca
se envían en cantidad 100 cajas Por
ejemplo si en cajas reportarán 180
millones de dólares el mercado Saudita
es el más importante
solíamos ir de aquí a Dubai o de Siria a
Jordania y luego Arabia Saudita o de
África a Arabia Saudita todo acaba en
Arabia Saudita hay mucha demanda ya como
resultado Siria es la Fuente del 80% del
tráfico mundial de captagón
y esta red reuniría según los expertos a
varones de la droga hombres de negocios
tribus beduinas así como al régimen
Rebeldes y organizaciones como gesbolá
en un tráfico muy lucrativo que habría
permitido la convergencia de intereses
entre las partes en conflicto
en el contexto de la guerra civil en
Siria como en otros lugares existe lo
que llamamos un terreno fértil para el
tráfico de drogas en particular
muchos grupos están interesados en este
tráfico Simplemente porque hay un
problema de financiamiento y los
enemigos declarados pueden considerar de
vez en cuando que puede haber
convergencias en aras del interés
financiero
hay tránsitos que se pueden hacer porque
a todos les interesa en un momento dado
ganar dinero
Pero esto no sería una amistad ni
siquiera una alianza
con una economía paralizada por una
década de guerra y sanciones Siria acabó
convirtiéndose en un narcoestado
el tráfico nunca se detendrá continuará
no acabará y con la actual inestabilidad
social y política del país se espera que
el tráfico de captaron crezca aún más